♪♪
-Of all the movies
that I've made, it's like --
"Bad Boys" was the one that
people would say the most,
"Hey, man,
when you gonna do another one?
When you doing another?"
You know.
Nobody's walking up and saying,
"Man, I can't wait to see
'Pursuit of Happyness 2.'"
-I'm fierce!
-These are my nipples,
not my eyes.
-This is inspired by Beyoncé.
And I'm like, "Well,
I just dress her.
She's never wearing that."
You know what I mean?
-...filled your resume
with lies.
-Oh, yeah, well, I didn't
have a lot of credits.
-Yeah.
-So I had a very large
"special skills" section.
-Yeah.
-I wrote everything
that I could do.
-Right, just 'cause you
had to fill out the page.
-Yeah, automobile driver.
Automobile driver-
slash-automatic.
[ Laughter ]
Automobile driver-
slash-manual.
[ Cheers ]
-Markling.
Let's see the definition.
It's when you can't handle
your boyfriend's family,
so you move to Canada.
She was here, and she did say
that you maybe
used your hands to eat
out of her pot.
-Okay, let me clarify.
It was the end of
the evening.
That pot roast was fierce.
You know that kind of food
that makes you want
to throw your shoe
at somebody?
-Yeah.
-That.
And I walked past
and I just... [ Murmuring ]
And she saw me do it.
-[ Laughs ]
-And she's a little
germaphobe, so...
-Oh, gotcha.
-She made me take
the pot licker home.
Next, we have paper straw.
Let's see the definition.
It's a replacement for your
ex who is better for you,
but ends up being
weak and useless.
[ Laughter ]
-I have had a lot of jobs.
I was -- Baker Square Pie Shop.
I was a waitress
there for many years.
My first job was as a car hop
at A&W,
where back then they made us
wear a very tight t-shirt
that said
"Take home a jug of fun."
-Oh, my God.
-Yeah, that has been --
They've stopped doing that.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-There is no doubt
that there were a series
of imminent attacks that were
being plotted by
Qasem Soleimani.
We don't know precisely when,
and we don't know
precisely where.
But it was real.
-When you say the attacks
were imminent,
how imminent were they?
Are we talking about days,
we talking about weeks?
-If you're an American
in the region,
days and weeks -- this is not
something that's relevant.
-These guys claim there's
an imminent attack,
and then when you ask them
for specifics,
suddenly they turn into
characters in a French film.
[ French accent ] Days, weeks,
what is the difference?
Weeks are days,
days are weeks.
What matters is love, no?
-What we've done with
the USMCA,
what we've done with Japan --
$40 billion trade deal,
and a lot of it has to do
with the farmers.
South Korea.
Oh, you gotta love Trump.
You gotta love Trump.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-No, we [chuckling] don't.
Trump is so
detached from reality,
he's starting to talk like
a sitcom character
doing his catchphrase.
[as Trump] Uh-oh. Looks like
the kitchen's on fire
and the cops are here.
Still,
you gotta love Trump!
[ Whimsical sting plays ]
[ Applause and cheering ]
-They were doing a local news
segment on, like, abstinence
as a part of teen sex education.
And, like, my guidance
counselor, for some reason
was like, "I'll ask 14-year-olds
to talk about sex." You know?
"And I'll ask John, who's
clearly gay and not out...
-When you went and sat down,
were you like,
"I was made for this?"
Or were you --
-Well, that's what
typically happens.
Like, tonight, for example,
it's like --
I'm backstage in this
see-through shirt.
I'm like, "I got this."
And then the second I'm out
here, I'm like, "Oops."
-And finally, you probably heard
the slang term, FOMO,
the fear of missing out,
and JOMO,
the joy of missing out.
Well, this is NSFOWOTOMO.
This is "no strong feelings
one way or the other
about missing out."
[ Laughter ]
"Tina had a party last night,
but apparently it wasn't huge
or anything.
Some people had fun
and some didn't,
and they watched a movie,
but it was 'Spider-Man:
Far From Home,'
and I've already seen it.
It was pretty good,
but I don't know if I need
to see it again.
Anyway, #NSFOWOTOMO."
[ Laughter ]
-I'll tell you
a little bit about myself.
I'm mixed race,
which means I should be hot.
[ Laughter ]
-My grandmother
found my rap book.
And she just turned --
she never said nothing.
Turned to the back page
and she said, "Dear Willard,
truly intelligent people
do not have to use words
like this to express themselves.
Please show the world
that you're as smart
as we think you are.
Love, Gigi."
-Oh, my God.
[ Audience aws ]
-I read that, and I was like,
[Bleep].
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I don't know how we're going
to top that.
♪♪